today we are learning a bit more about a
murder-suicide investigation involving a
police officer it happened near lake
mead and simmons up in north las vegas
christian casares has been working on
this story joins us now live in studio
with more that's right brian neighbors
tell me they were shocked to see this
scene play out outside of their home and
a bigger surprise when they learned
their neighbor was part of law
enforcement
this was the scene sunday morning that
many neighbors tell us felt chaotic
dozens of police officers including the
swat team blocking all access on
perryville avenue a gated community in
north las vegas and rattling nerves for
neighbors like mark harris all i heard
was a big boom
they woke me up and
i thought it was fireworks according to
north las vegas police an off-duty
officer got into an argument with his
wife sunday morning after a night out as
the man threatened to kill his wife and
daughter their son was shot in the hand
that's when the wife and son ran out of
the home to get help she ran around that
corner
because they had those cones they had
those cones all the way around the
corner the blood spot i guess that's
probably from her son's hand police say
around four in the morning the off-duty
officer shot his daughter and himself
inside the home harris says the officer
he knew as easy kept to himself so much
he didn't know he was a police officer
he always working out he always speaking
to my grandkids
him and his wife was always working out
together riding the bikes together
so
he was
he was a good cat this video shared to 8
news now by a resident who doesn't want
to be identified shows several police
officers around the home moments later
the garage door is blown out as officers
forced their way inside they tore it up
they tore the garage up and the windows
of the ball busted out yes i saw it
yeah and you're looking on the outside
oh they're living good they're doing
great but on the inside
something going on
well we do want to remind you that there
is a new 988 suicide hotline number
available right now if you or anyone
that you know needs any assistance
christian gaza is live local now
christian and just in a statement from
north las vegas police it came out
minutes ago it reads in part the
off-duty north las vegas police officer
involved in the tragic incident was
israel molina
he was a six-year veteran to the force
and assigned a patrol our hearts truly
go out to the family we offer our
deepest condolences to all those
affected